we try to make the exact stuff that we
would want to launch and a lot of it is
a lot of those things I would only stand
out and all you guys are something
different and that different thing is
functioning laser guns this feels really
unnecessary well I completely disagree I
should think it's pretty cool
yeah it's very fulfilling to watch
something and really feel like if you
had nothing to do with it you'd be
really jealous of the people who made it
look who it is mr. star the show's
helped us understand what an amazing
surprise cuz I surprised you told me
just stand here and wait so when you
know you're signing on to a program
project our idea that you had about
what's going to be going on with respect
or if expecting a second expect the
unexpected man I mean I just knew I had
to jump in both feet not even think
about it just go for it and that's what
we did co-starring Eliza coupe all
episodes of future man will be streaming
on November 14th but Josh won't be
telling his whole family about the
raunchy series I don't want any grandmas
of mine to see this show let's just say
that I want to edit a very different
version of the show dust of the day yeah
Josh's grandma
Julian I have no idea I've not heard
from his Josh's grandma yet I normally
check in with the grandmothers of all
the stars of our of our projects but
I've neglected